- I heard that you met
your girl on Instagram.
- I did, yeah.
- That is crazy,
'cause that can go real
south, I'm just saying.
- Well, here's what I did
though, here's what I did.
- Okay.
- 'Cause I knew it could go south
because it's online dating, I mean--
- [Kelly] Yeah, and you're famous.
- [Dustin] The position I was in,
(Kelly laughing)
it's tough to meet people.
I don't get to go out a whole lot.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Dustin] So, I was like
you know what I'll do?
I'll invite her to a
show and if she sucks,
I can just (Kelly laughing)
Or if its weird, I can just go,
"Have fun at the show."
And security's there, gates
are there, I'm good Saint.
- That's amazing!
- But see, she wasn't weird.
- Oh, that's awesome!
(audience clapping)
- Always gotta have an out.
- Have y'all ever met
someone on social media?
You got married within
three months, Alano.
- I did.
That is a crazy great three months.
- Yeah, and we've been
married for 11 years.
- That's amazing.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- I'm just saying if I'm
dating someone for three months
and I'm like, "Wait getting married?
"You haven't even seen the ugly side yet."
- That's what I said!
She was like, "We'll figure
it out when we get married."
- Did you guys get to do holidays
within those three months or is it--
- Nope.
- No, wow.
- No, I met her father
and you know he said,
"Well if she'll have you, you can--"
(everyone laughing)
- Oh my gosh!
- I was like, "Okay."
- [Rosario] And they say romance is dead.
- I know. I did the right thing.
- [Kelly] You did.
- I'm from the south, so I
went to talk to her father
and he said, "Well, she'll have you."
So okay. That's I blessing I guess.
- I guess you're fine.
(Kelly and Alano laughing)
Also, this is hilarious.
I hear you have--it's not
hilarious it's awesome
I have a girl crush on her as well but--
- [Kelly] You love Reba McEntire.
- Oh, yes.
- That is amazing!
- She's always been my celebrity crush.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Yes! Look at you!
- [Dustin] There we are!
- [Kelly] That's so great!
- That's one of the
coolest nights of my life.
That's me getting inducted
into the Grand Ole Opry family.
- That is so amazing.
- I can't believe that was a surprise.
- With Reba there. That's amazing!
- I told my team I don't wanna
know who's gonna come out
and do the official induction
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- And freaking Reba McEntire walked out.
- Oh my gosh. And she's
so nice, she's so lovely.
- I have a weird object in my basement
that all my friends that come over
who haven't been there yet--
- I'm so excited by what's
about to come out of your mouth.
(laughing)
- You have a weird object
in your basement, go.
- Yeah so, I did a trophy
case from that night
with Reba, from the Grand Ole Opry
and it's that trophy
and then there's this
tissue paper that's there
and people are like, "What is that?"
And so we started crying,
she was saying such sweet
and important things to me
I started bawling on stage.
And then she goes, "And
to sing his first song
"as the Grand Ole Opry
member, here's Dustin Lynch."
And I'm just a mess, crying on stage.
And she ran offstage, grabs me tissues,
and then runs back onstage
and hands me tissues.
So, that's my weird object. That tissue--
- Oh my god!
- [Dustin] That is weird
right? It's kinda gross.
- That's not weird! That's really sweet.
You made yourself sound like
some kind of serial killer,
and now you're actually really sweet.
- It is kinda creepy
though, I save tissues--
- It's not creepy! It's not creepy.
If Meryl Streep handed me something
she was crying on, I'd keep it.
- There in a frame?
- (Kelly laughing) Oh,
yeah, yes, with a plaque.
She touched my face!
I'm just kidding, Meryl.
You planned on studying medicine,
which I think is amazing.
You got accepted into a
school, you were gonna go--
- As a surgeon, yeah.
- How did parents take that news?
- Not great.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I don't think so.
- Not at all no.
I mean, I promised my
parents I would graduate
and when I got to college, I fell in love
with how the human body works,
so it's a natural progression
to get to med school.
But then, I just had this,
"What if?" down inside
and I was like, "Man I
gotta chase this dream.
"I have to try it."
- Yeah.
- If it doesn't work out, fine.
But I went and told my
parents that I would be
putting off med school to go and play
for tips in a jar at a hockey time.
Trying to make rent--
- Oh my god. That's every parents' dream.
- My dad backed me up
to the wall in the hallway pretty quick.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a southern daddy.
- But it worked out.
- So here is the best part, though.
So I hear that the only C you've received
in high school was in music class.
- Yes. That's it.
And more importantly, vocal music.
(Kelly laughing)
Vocal music too, is the class.
- So after your parents knowing that,
did it make harder?
- That's probably what
they were leaning on.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But honestly, at that point,
I had been playing at a lot
of bars and frat parties,
a lot of college events
around the south east.
- Yeah.
- So, I think they were a
little bit confused, you know?
- Yeah.
- So, they gave me their blessing and--
- Yeah, you gotta follow your dream.
You want your baby to follow their dreams.
- And honestly, dad, I thought he was
gonna punch me in my
throat whenever I told him.
- Yup, southern dad.
- But he was the first guy to
be driving us to and from gigs
and helping us set up
right after that, so.
- That's so cool!
They've gotten to do this
whole thing with you.
- I know, yeah--
- And then you're with
Reba McIntire onstage
doing your tears with your tissues.
Show the tissue all the
time to your family.
(Dustin laughing)
So we've been asking everybody
what their campaign slogan would be,
your presidential campaign slogan.
- Yes.
- So it's your name, it's
the year you wanna run,
and it's your last text.
- Okay.
I know what it is, actually.
Dustin Lynch, 2048, drink, drink, drink.
(everyone cheering)
- Oh god!
- [Dustin] That would work.
- [Kelly] I mean, y'all's
totally beats mine.
Mine was so dumb.
- [Dustin] What was yours?
- I'm so mad, I'm so
competitive. Mine is so long
I don't even remember
it; I was apologizing
'cause I didn't return some text
and I was so long-winded about it.
(gasps) I'm dumb.
- Grimace face was great though.
I send grimace faces all the time.
- [Kelly] Yeah grimace
face is the last one.
- Grimace face.
(Dustin laughing)